author and columnist mark Stein joins us
now I have a feeling you have a few
things to say mark welcome aboard hey
great to be with you Tommy yeah look
this is it's very interesting I mean
there's I agree with Alexandria and no
one wants to go back but I don't think
anyone wants to go back to having their
two jobs delivering pizza either because
this is going to be a rough primary and
certainly would be an even rougher
general election what do you think is
his biggest liability is it his skin
color is it his age is it being
associated with the past what what do
you think they're looking at here well I
don't I don't think it's his skin color
or it's or his age because as much as I
enjoy hearing all these people beat up
on a 76 year old white man his principal
rival in the Democrat primary is the 77
year old white man and the difference
between them I think is that Bernie is a
romance for his supporters he's a
romantic figure he's a romantic insane
figure but he is romantic Biden is tired
and is in the awful position of being
unable to run as himself because the
Democrats are basically disowned 90% of
what Joe Biden has been doing in
Washington the last 45 years so that's a
terrible problem for a guy when you have
to run in a and essentially dishonest
way which is why he gave this tortured
and weird rationale as to why he's
decided to get into the race in in this
video so Bernie has it way easier Bernie
just has to be Bernie and Biden is
trying to be something other than Biden
yeah in the video it was interesting in
that he really based it in
Charlottesville and it seemed as though
that it was this fear that all of
America what had become racist and he's
supposed to be the moderate and yet that
is the rhetoric of the of the left and
the rhetoric of the left really also is
kind of sexist and and racist in a way
an ageist for a group that's politically
correct if they seem to be moving into
an arena that they used to condemn
people for well it is very interesting
that old people
people you can beat up on and I think
that's to do with the fact that Democrat
ideology essentially now is living in a
kind of hyper present tense right so the
only thing that happened before the day
before yesterday is entirely irrelevant
so that means the people who exemplify
it that's you know candidates who are
older than 12 years old can be beaten up
on the grounds of their age but Biden
doesn't even do the old thing well
because say what you like about Russian
collusion but the the basic premise of
the Russian collusion fever was that
Trump was some kind of deep sleeper or
not so deep sleeper for Vladimir Putin
that doesn't indict all Trump supporters
right it's weird thing that that Trump
somehow is leading to this resurgence of
white supremacism necessarily indict
snot just Trump and half half the
population of the country change well
well that that's it and it's and it's
difficult to have to fit into that now
and the other but older white man Bernie
Sanders last night
attended an event called Shiva people a
woman in the crowd asks Anders what he'd
do to fight against so-called white
nationalism when he evaded giving an
answer mark he began to get heckled he
listen to this the poor the question is
about as president what would you do
with the rise of white supremacy Iowa or
protect our communities
you know as somebody who I know I date
myself a little bit here but I actually
was at the march on Washington with dr.
King back in 1963 and boy he got booed
for mentioning that what's going on
there mark well I think birdy in
fairness to him well I'll say one thing
by the way he looks fabulous there he
doesn't look 77 he looks like 83 97
maybe but you can tell he's actually
serious about running for president
because he lives just across the
Connecticut River from me in in Vermont
and he looks more quest and groom than
I've ever seen him so he's serious yes
yes seriously I think he's ready to take
it to take it on but this is just a one
I think one kind of taste of what
everyone can expect in this Democratic
primary season mark thank you so much
appreciate you coming with being with
you too dear